this camp for displaced people in
northern cameroon houses tens of
thousands of refugees many of them come
from the central african republic now
300 people are being repatriated hoping
to pick up where they left off or hoping
to start over
it's been eight years since i fled the
conflict to cameroon i came with my
husband and grandmother i'm not afraid
to go back because my neighbor who was
here with me has already left she helps
me a lot i just want to go back guardio
camp was set up in 2014 to accommodate
10 000 central africans fleeing fighting
between the government and seleka rebels
as the conflict intensified it's grown
and now hosts more than 10 times that
number
funding shortfalls as well as limited
humanitarian assistance and access to
basic services has led to deteriorating
conditions in the camp
when we first arrived i was happy in
cameroon but things got bad because of
the hospital and lack of food
to eat you're jostled by other people
from left to right and that's what's
pushing me to go home
hundreds of people have been repatriated
since the u.n backed process began in
2019 however the organization says the
decision is ultimately up to the
refugees themselves
repatriation is done on a voluntary
basis it is the first of all elements
that must be taken into consideration
and we unhcr give refugees the mapping
of safe areas in car and it is the
refugees who opt for return we do not
promote repatriation we facilitate that
is to say the refugee is aware of the
decision and we help him to return to
his country
the conflict in the central african
republic is not over and the
humanitarian situation is dire the world
food program estimates more than half of
the population of 5 million people don't
know where their next meal will come
from
and while many of these refugees say all
they remember of the villages they left
behind is death and devastation they'd
rather rebuild what's been destroyed in
their home country rather than live in
limbo elsewhere hippomorgan al jazeera